thank you so much for joining us I am
Yasmine Abdul majeed and I'm delighted
to welcome you to this event on
portraiture race and British history
we're here in the stately surrounds of
Harewood house a country estate in West
Yorkshire with a history that's deeply
rooted in the transatlantic slave trade
and will be unpacking some of this
tangle past in our conversation this
evening but first of all why are we here
and why now
for those of you in the room you can see
that we're surrounded by portraits
there's a Sea of Faces behind me so I've
called it the White Hall of Fame and
many of the portraits shown at Harewood
house represent members of the lassos
family following the tradition of
stately homes across the country
the ground this house was built on was
bought by Henry lassells in 1738 with
money gained directly from the sugar
trade so in other words through owning
plantations enslaved people ships
warehouses Etc
his eldest son Henry's eldest son Edwin
the first Baron Hayward was born in
Barbados and went to use the wealth
generated from the family business to
build and furnish the house we're in
right now
but for several centuries if you looked
at the walls of this house there were no
obvious signs of the history or the
origins of harewood's wealth
so this event
coincides with the first installment of
missing portraits a series of
commissioned photographic portraits
initiated by David lassells and hen and
Diane house the Earl and Countess of
Harewood the portraits focus on people
of African Caribbean Heritage with a
particular connection to Haywood house
the first portrait which you can see in
this room is of Dr Arthur France who's
actually here with us tonight which is
lovely Arthur France is in the first row
thank you
made by leeds-based artist and filmmaker
Ashley Carell who's also in the audience
today
[Applause]
Arthur France is a leading Community
activist and the founder of Leeds West
Indian carnival which predates its Mo
its more famous sister event in Notting
Hill and I'm sure Dr Arthur will tell
you all about the festival here in Leeds
or the carnival here in Leeds
now each portrait has been specially
commissioned to redress the historic
lack of diversity in harewood's art
collection and create awareness about
its Colonial past
missing portraits is one of many
initiatives that form part of hayward's
open history program a long-standing
commitment to being transparent about
its past
tackling racism and promoting equality
and inclusion
this evening is an opportunity to
experience this in action
conversation about
story relates to Britain's wider story
so let me introduce our wonderful panel
for tonight
so we have uh in the Glorious whites we
have Moya Lothian McLean or McLean sorry
is a journalist and contributing editor
at Novara media and is also the host of
Human Resources a podcast by broccoli
content about Britain's slaving past
let's give my Round of Applause
foreign it is also a great podcast which
I highly recommend I know there's many
podcasts out there it's a crowded Market
but I highly recommend we have right
next to me Dr Nicholas cullinan
um the director of the National Portrait
Gallery which is set to reopen in June
2023 this year following a major
Redevelopment the largest transformation
that the gallery has seen since it
opened in 1896 let's give documents
[Applause]
right at the end we have Thomas J Price
an artist and sculptor of very famous
artist in sculptor yes whose work deals
with questions of representation power
and status in 2022 he was commissioned
by Hackney Council to create a permanent
public sculpture in commemoration of the
Windrush generation thank you Thomas
[Applause]
and finally we have David lassells the
eighth Earl of Hayward David has worked
as a film producer for more than 20
years and was the chairman of the
Harewood house trust for many years
along with his wife Diane who's also in
the audience he has sought to promote
the power of the Arts as a vehicle for
social change whether that's through
fighting racism or promoting
environmental stewardship thank you
David
[Applause]
so before we begin and get into the
juicy conversation a little bit of
housekeeping please check your phones as
usual and make sure they're off or on
silent this is the moment for you to do
that it's all good the conversation will
run for just under an hour and we'll
have 20 minutes or so for questions at
the end so please do keep questions in
mind
um and if I don't know I should actually
check my iPhone but that's fine if
you're watching online
um please do drop questions in the chat
as well we would love to have questions
from the audience and also due to the
train strikes tomorrow solidarity with
all the strikers we have a hard stop at
7 45 pm to make sure everyone gets home
on time so don't wait too long to ask
your questions because we'll stop at 7
45.
so let's begin David I want to ask I
want to start with you um to find out a
little bit more about the aims behind
the missing portraits pro project and
the idea of the missing portraits can
you tell us a little bit about your
approach to representing harewood's
history and why focus on the idea of
missing portraits in particular well it
was um it was my wife Diane's idea
really initially and it grew after the
fact that there are in this house I've
never counted actually but but probably
hundreds of portraits of uh of different
people mostly As you say members of the
lassos family or people connected to the
lassos family so all of them white all
of them Rich all of them
in people of privilege
of course at that time the 18th and 19th
century which you could say is the kind
of Heyday of of a portraiture
um if you
if you've made it whatever fear you've
made it in a successful military man as
a businessman uh as a property owners or
whatever it may be you had your portrait
painted by the most by the best Portrait
Painter that you could afford
um that was that was very much part of
of having made it in those days so as I
said there's hundreds of portraits here
but in a way they so but they represent
Ash houses like this there's so many
historic properties in this country do
they represent actually a very narrow
view of that of that history
nothing we can do about that nothing we
can do to change the way that as
represented historically
but there was a way Diane's idea of of
what she calls a retrofitting The
Collection by making new portraits in
the style of these 18th and 19th century
portions I mean photographer we decided
we wanted to do them photographically
it's been a you know probably the the
strongest present day portrait tradition
um but very much the missile of those
historic portraits both in the way uh
they were lit the way the poser was
sitting and the way they were framed as
you can see in the portrait of Arthur
there at the end with the idea that
those would then um that we then create
an exhibition around the person who
wrote about telling them why they're why
they're important why their lives are
important why what their connection with
with this place is and then after the
exhibition uh ends that will become part
of the permanent connection and we would
as it were slip them in amongst the
portraits in the house and they should
be more indistinguishable from those but
they fitted well on those walls and
people will go around and look at them
and they will I'm sure people will be
who's that why is he here and that's
exactly the question that we want to be
that we want people to ask why don't you
start having that conversation something
interesting starts to go out of it I
think I
I'm sort of wandering around
one of the
in a sort of positive way because you
know it's something that Nick did you
want to respond to I saw a lot of
nodding so I thought I might talk to you
um no it's just really interesting to
hear about your challenges and what
you've been doing and it's not
dissimilar to what we're doing at the
national Portugal novices you said we've
been closed for some time doing this
transformation project and that has
always been with the idea of thinking
about our collection and how we
communicated to our visitors and the
projects began with lots of visitor
research and understanding you know why
people came to the gallery all different
types of audiences what they loved what
they didn't like and also why people
didn't come to the gallery and what came
through from all that research is that
you know all of our audiences whether
they were a sort of you know
long-standing audience or a new audience
they all wanted it to represent Britain
now in all of its complexity obviously
we look often at Britain's past but it
needs to reflect the Britain of now as
well and everyone I think is as you've
mentioned should really wanted more
transparency and a sense of kind of
honesty about Britain's past and in a
way marking the change too from then and
now so as you were saying we've been
thinking about ways to fill in gaps to
bring in contemporary artists to fill in
gaps and that's something we'll do uh
throughout the building also with Thomas
which we'll talk about later on I'm sure
but also to bring out stories that are
already in the collection and for
example and it's kind of interesting
because in a way it's almost
self-selecting so one of our most
popular portraits that's the most for a
while was the most searched for image on
our website of every British person ever
living was seraphor spinetta that
extraordinary woman from the 19th
century who was a Yoruba princess who
was brought to the to London really
against her will and was then adopted by
Queen Victoria as her goddaughter and
spent the rest of her life here and we
have these two extraordinary images of
her by uh Camille Sylvie a 19th century
photographer and one of those images has
become the most searched for image on
our website and so one thing that we'll
do is think about also because there's
questions too about scale like
photography alongside painting can be
19th century photography which is quite
small can be sort of drowned out so
we're thinking very carefully about you
know scale balance and as you said sort
of how to surprise people and how to
bring in stories that were perhaps you
know there but not shown or missing
um through and it will begin in The
Tudor period it'll begin with uh John
blank who was a Trumpeter in the court
of Henry VII and Henry VII and the first
person of color to be depicted in this
country so it's woven all the way
through and I'll just say one final
thing and then I'll shut up
um
I just don't want to have a good
conversation but we have a really good
Advisory Group and one thing that's very
interesting is you know the national
portugari so obviously we tell the story
of Britain through portraiture and we we
have a twofold challenge and an
opportunity one is to tell a transparent
story of Britain and Empire in slavery
as you're doing here
but what was very clear to you from our
Advisory Group is that it would be it
could also be offensive to only tell the
story of the black presence in Britain
until wind rush through slavery and so
we've been very focused on also how to
find stories about Transcendence and
agency and emancipation to run alongside
the other narrative so there's two
narratives that need to be told and
woven through but I'll stop at that
point oh you've given us so
so we'll come back to a lot of that and
at that thank you and so Thomas I might
bring you in at this point
um Harley I'm curious actually if you
have any thoughts on the idea that you
know this particular image of you know a
black woman a Euro woman is like the
most searched for image and all of your
collection that that seems interesting
to me and I'm curious if you have any
thoughts on that but the question kind
of associated with your work is about
this idea of portraiture because you're
a sculptor and many of your Works have
like a portrait like feeling but you
resist the label of well you don't you
don't describe them as being portraits
so I'm curious about your relationship
with the idea of portraiture and
depicting people you know just that
small question
thank you
um I'm really interested in the desire
to be portrayed I'm really interested in
that desire to for one another to
connect so is that idea about empathy
and about being included about existing
and being made to feel that you exist
and that you're valued and I think I
sort of fell into this sort of style of
portraiture I came from a background
which was very much about what's
happening internally so I was using
abstract ways to present emotion
feelings
um probably at a time when it wasn't
particularly fashionable to do so
um I then sort of realized that if I
really want to collect this book to
connect to people and get people
connected to the works and really
feeling able to talk about the works
they felt most able to comment on
something that they could recognize and
they felt most
able to comment on a person and it was
actually through this desire to create
empathy and experiment with moments of
empathy moments of connection or failure
to connect
that race was placed upon the works that
I was creating because actually
initially I was sculpting and doing
animation stop-motion animations
to kind of recreate blinks and slight
movements and try to here we go
um to create this sort of this
experience of presence and this
experience of Engagement with a a an
object which became a personality and a
personality that came you and if it
didn't you were in a space where you
were able to examine why that was why
that was the case
um and it wasn't until I did a an
animation of the first black characters
initially I was observing people I was
that weirdo on the bus that would be
looking at you and
um and it was my peers at the time who
who couldn't get past the fact that this
character had to be black and for me I
was a sculpting a person and so
subsequently throughout my practice I
was I was experimenting even more and
pushing this sort of
it's about this barrier you know working
with the blackness
but in a way that I didn't address it I
didn't verbally address it I was making
people what do you mean you know because
I've always said it's a bit of a cop-out
perhaps but it's true is that the works
are what you bring to them
and I think it's a really interesting
experiment to have going on in terms of
what we bring to these people and in
different contexts so it's you know it's
incredible to be here this evening in
this environment and so I don't know
this I won't talk so much but in terms
of like this idea of portrait children's
you're all apologizing for speaking but
that's exactly what people probably
you're probably use like you know going
off on Long tangents by ourselves
um I'm aware of people to speak but it's
it's interesting this idea of
portraiture
the desire to be portrayed this idea of
being as good as this historical genre
and I guess within my Works which is
very important to note that they're
actually they're made up characters
these are not portraits of individuals
these are physio physically only kind of
like elements put together to create
experiments and dealing with material
and scale was also important in terms of
dealing with status why was that
important to you
um for it not to be like one person in
particular because that's you know in
the history of portraiture as I
understand it it's you know it's about
you're painting a particular person
you're depicting a particular person
yeah I mean it's the status attached to
who has created this portrait that's one
element of status uh the material that
works or created it so like this idea I
thought very interesting in terms of
Photography versus something painted
because obviously there's still that
conversation in terms of like which has
more value
in terms of what takes more time you
know thank you well I see you I see you
writing notes so I'm coming to you I'm
coming to do you want to respond to that
and then we'll we'll talk a little bit
about your podcast as well do I want to
respond to that um I think picking up on
what you said about this desire to be
betrayed is also this desire to be
remembered that's something I think
about a lot in when we're making this
podcast and the stories that we're
telling uh I think in this country we
obviously have a great man theory of
history that we most often return to
again and again and it's this idea about
who gets represented throughout history
and I think something I really want to
do with the podcast was not try and
frame the histories that we're telling
through that that lens so I didn't want
to just do it in a way of these people
should be treating the same as Napoleon
because I don't think that's the way
history should be told it should be
texted in a different way it should be
treated in a different way one of my
favorite episodes that we do is when
we're talking about oral Histories on
the west coast of um what is now Ghana
um and how people remember history then
how completely different it is to
Western histories and how the way that
people are framed in that so yeah
there's this idea who want why do You
Want To Be Remembered in this particular
let through this particular level this
particular way and how can we break away
from that what are alternative ways of
remembering and that's what makes I
think this more exciting when we start
pushing through that and a lot of the
work that I see museums do now is really
great but often it is taking these
histories and remembering through the
traditional lens and
I think the next step is thinking about
how we can push that even further and
break those those sort of like
um entrenched ideas of remembrance down
altogether thank you Moy I think that
the idea and the idea of the desire to
be remembered is quite interesting
because and actually David I wonder if I
could get you to pick up on that and
because in a way this house so does so
much remembering right you've got all of
these portraits of people who were
interested in being remembered and I'm
I'm just I'm curious to sort of hear
what your thoughts are on this idea of
the desire to be remembered
well that's very much what places like
this were built to do weren't they they
were built to be a great homage to
um
feel wealth your taste your status all
those things actually one interesting
thing about
portraits talk about missing portraits
there's one really significant missing
portrait in this house which of the
Henry Russell who made the money in the
first place there's no portrait of it
and no portrait known of him and that's
a mystery that I have no answer to very
straight for all the reasons we said
earlier have you have a very successful
man in his own lifetime in a hobber
abhorrent trade but that he was very
successful
and it wasn't even that he was written
out of a family history you know Henry
every every oldest son since has had
Henry in his names I'm David David Henry
George
um actually none of my kids are called
Henry but that's another sure
so that's strange sorry slightly off the
topic of what you're saying but there
but in what is remembered and who is
remembered and why you know houses like
this are all about tend to be just about
that remember me a great portrait of the
great me and here in the background is
the house that I built or the Terrace
that I built or here are the uh
paintings that I commissioned or they uh
the porcelain that I bought or whatever
it might be is all about glorifying
those those things and and the objects
involved are beautiful some of the most
beautifully made beautifully crafted
objects ever but that's
it's easy to get distracted by that they
also have a story behind them obviously
I'm not an art historian I'm a filmmaker
by profession so I understand you know
the importance of being able to tell
stories about things so often the story
behind things is of interesting the most
important but even more so than the
actual object itself Moy I'm going to
come back to you on that because I I'm
other societies described or had other
ways about of memory are there any in
particular that you know this yeah maybe
I'll leave you with that question if you
want to think on it but I'm curious
about
um yeah about you know other ways of
memory or other ways of remembering and
other ways of telling story that you
know perhaps speak to this idea of not
everybody wanting to necessarily be
portrayed or depicted but not wanting to
lose something
I mean if I had the answer to that I
would be running the National Portrait
Gallery
but when I when I think when I think
about this what I've been thinking about
recently is when I go to
like Howard or museums galleries Etc
um and I think about the things that
really strike me and stand out in the
way that they are presenting a narrative
and some of those that I'm most struck
by and this may seem like a tangent but
um I went to Paris recently and went to
the Thierry mugler exhibition and they
had a whole room which was just on a
factory it was just smells and I thought
I was always stay with me like a state
of me this idea that we just went in we
just smelled that and the clothes that
were placed on the models there in
another room something they were brought
to life because you could see them on
people and it's this idea of I guess
Thinking Beyond just these stayed
objects here's a written history here's
that how can you bring it like more and
more places are experimenting with this
idea of like playing sound interaction
oral there was a really good Exhibition
at the design Museum recently which is
all just touch and but when we're
thinking about for example uh the
history of particularly afro-caribbean
people in the UK or formerly enslaved
peoples um just I guess the black
population in the UK and its presence
throughout history how can we tell that
Beyond a collection which is uh simply a
pair of handcuffs or a piece of plank
for wood what is you know there's
walking tours which I find really really
evocative at the moment
um and that's like they went to in Paris
which was walking around the black
neighborhoods of Paris but it took it
further and there was like this you know
this Stone what does this represent and
it was actually a memorial to a young
man who'd been killed in the 1980s by
the Parisian police there and he was a I
think a young man from I want to say
Senegal but it might be Morocco actually
um but it's those kind of things where
it's a different way and it brings the
parts of the story story to life in a
very humanizing way and adds a texture
Beyond simply you stand here and you
read this off a plaque and that is
history how do we tell these stories in
a way that makes that person real to you
and something I think about a lot is in
the podcast there's this one anecdote
that I talk about constantly because
it's so evocative and I was talking to
Dr Steve buckridge who's a like textiles
historian and he were talking about
um fabric that enslaved populations in
Jamaica and further in the Caribbean
were clothed by which was often made in
places like Wales interesting on its own
like a really fascinating story and then
he said have you heard of lace bark and
I was like what's lacebark he said to me
well lacebark was what the black African
women would make out of bark they made
this amazing lace they would soak the
bark in in water for hours an hour's
name is fantastic delicate lace that
looked just like the European lakes and
of course at this point in time black
African enslaved women were not meant to
be wearing lace that was not the thing
and I suddenly had this image of these
women and because it's another thing I
didn't know about the slow populations
is that they actually not time off but
they had time when they sometimes were
on the plantation they had Sunday
markets they had these whole lives as
well that were obviously constrained and
curtailed by their enslavement but they
built this community Unity like that's
only brought to life to me these women
wearing this like Rich lace that they've
made from barks or trees and something
was there I could see them they were
real to me they're right in front of me
and that's what I think about when we're
talking about these histories how do we
make that person be standing right in
front of you so you can see them you can
hear them you can start the song you're
there that's what I'd like from the
museums
well fortunately we have someone
would you like to respond to that Nick
I'm sure you've been thinking about
these things yeah I mean it's a really
it's a great Point uh there's a tall
order as well but I think um yeah no
you're totally right and I think I mean
we've been thinking a lot about this and
it's kind of interesting as well like
I've just been writing the essay for our
new book when we open which is about the
history of the National Portrait Gallery
and it's a very like for a country to
have a Portugal is a very particular
thing we were the first of the worlds
when we were founded in 1856 and just
reading through the history and it's
just it's very interesting because it's
in a way there's a kind of Continuum
between when we were founded in the
Victorian era as you said you know at
the heights of empire in a very
different time but even then we had two
kind of aims one was to give people uh
examples of individuals to emulate or
aspire to but also to show people in all
of their complexity and their faults and
I think that's super interesting and
it's been very interesting also working
on this rehang you know during these
kind of culture wars over the last two
years which are very divisive and kind
of reductive in some total and I I think
a lot of people have a great sense of
curiosity and have the intelligence to
understand complexity and how good and
bad
can exist simultaneously and I think in
the same person exactly or or we were
saying before with with Diane that you
can look at a beautiful object and
understand that there's also terrible
things around it and it doesn't it
doesn't take away the beauty of the
objects but actually understanding the
awful things around it add to the
complexity and I think we need to get to
this point where we can have a kind of
complex understanding of the past it's
oh it's always a process of addition so
you know everything we're doing is not
to kind of take away or tear things down
is to kind of add to the complexity of
what's there is to add to the variety of
who's depicted is to hopefully encourage
a greater number of people of all
different walks of life to kind of come
and visit and explore and discuss and
ask the very questions that you are
asking and it's just about like if you
are a steward of a museum you want the
museum to kind of go on and Thrive and
that is through people and audiences so
this is your job so I encourage new
people you know bigger audiences to come
and ask questions and engage should be
critical I think it's interesting this
idea as well of not not seeing the the
additional things as a threat because
sometimes I feel like people think you
know museums have a one in one out
policy right like if we if we bring this
new thing then something has to go where
it doesn't yeah I mean would you both
like to respond to that yeah yeah I mean
well just to say like okay so when you
when you come in uh you'll still have
the tutor Gallery it'll now go back to
the plantagenets
um and so the all of the great things
that people love about the tudagari you
know I know that people come
specifically to the mpg to see those
portraits they will all be there and so
will John blank and this incredible
story of you know a Trumpeter and the
quarter Henry the seventh Henry VII and
it just adds to the variety and the
richness and hopefully the excitement of
of what's there
I mean my Point's slightly adjacent
which is just that when we're doing the
podcast this is something I think about
a lot in terms of not telling this
binary good or bad history
I think people can be quite scared this
idea of embracing the the this idea of
bad but that's what it is all history is
it's a full-throated like complex Beast
right you can't tell it in its entirety
unless you've shown the whole picture
that that is the history and I think
it's so sad in Britain that we're
missing out on all these different parts
that make ourselves we've siled off
different aspects because either it's
unpalatable or it's been
compartmentalized and it happened far
away well it didn't it it's something
that is you know when we talk about
enslavement we lived in a plantation
economy as a plantation society it's
affected everything from the way our
Railways have developed to the manor
houses we're sitting in right now but
also right down to the factory of
overdrafts you can't tell the history of
brick without understanding this history
and you can't you know we are here
because you were that it's that thing
but that shouldn't be something we shy
away from we should be excited to
explore that because then we find out
more about our past and I think one of
the reasons that this country now is so
mired and repeating the same mistakes
over and over again is because it's so
afraid to really confront us
um but we shouldn't be afraid of the
dark we've got lights
[Laughter]
Thomas I see you nodding there in the in
the yeah yeah a lot of nodding did you
wanna I mean
as somebody who's also practiced you
know you're a practicing artist all of
these you know if we want to use the
phrase cultural conversations but all of
this like really heightened stuff is
happening how how are you thinking about
are you trying not to think about it at
all
it's a tricky one
um I think this whole idea of a culture
war is being manufactured
um by certain entities who want that to
be a cultural because it it makes them
money uh keep people divided and makes a
lot of people money and it keeps us away
from
um drawing ourselves together to move
collectively in a direction that we
should or could be going in to actually
affect real change
um so I don't believe in the culture War
I think when you really get down to the
nuances of conversation if you talk to
someone who even is expressing fear that
they might tear down church or statue
because then everything is going to
disappear in their lives you know that's
not really what it's about they're
worried about change I think also this
this emotional element which is
expressed through the absolute
resistance to or fear of change comes
from suppression and a national
suppression so when you suppress it's
more so I'm going to suppress the story
of the United Kingdom you know the
history of the United Kingdom uh people
know you know it's built on a line and
you're terrified that line is going to
see the light of day and because what
happens because you're not given that
um that kind of incremental
uh journey to becoming comfortable and
becoming
um
sort of uh affair with it you know
you're not you don't know how to handle
it and the fear is just then it grows
and it grows and grows and then suddenly
there's a you know we just missed it but
you know there's a there's a sculpture
of a 12-foot black person oh no you know
the world is going to fall down
um
but it won't because
this is part of this this is the United
Kingdom We Exist you know we've built
the United Kingdom
this this place is literally built on
the money that was created for black
people
so to sign to tell black people to be
complicit in covering that up to be
quiet
don't look like yourself don't sound
like you because that's worrying
um I find
um mad but I've grown up in this country
you know you know you grew up in this
country you learn how to deal with it
you are indoctrinated into the ways of
getting along and I think it's when I
stopped trying to get along and I start
to make it work which really expressed
my experience as an individual which
then chimed with other people's
experiences
and then as a microcosm actually
connected to a general population
experience we all experience the the
suppression and the oppression of having
to be part of a system that is
essentially built against us
so yeah I mean that's why I find in
museums and and these institutions are
interesting and difficult places and
there's other artists who deal with the
very makeup of of the museums and and
the sort of the the import that they
give an object or give a story and
there's an ideal narrative you know I've
done a whole series of Works based on
provenance and narrative and who gets to
create that narrative and who gets to
speak for oneself like as an individual
you know if you're a pet person in
particular
professions you represent that whole
thing it's ridiculous but the pressure
is incredible when you're supposed to
just handle it like it's nothing
so when it comes to discussions like
this I'm really I said before that I
don't know where I stand I'm I think
it's amazing what you're doing I think
that wanting to be seen and wanting to
be remembered is really important but
remembered as what it's seen as what
like seen as a replication of of the
thing that was suppressing you or seen
as an actual individual who connects on
a real level to the people around you
I don't know like I make my work knowing
that the majority of people want to be
on a horse feeling Grand right I know
this because sometimes I'm there I want
to be I want to be respected
but I make my work as an alternative to
try and every now and again be there so
that we go oh good yeah you know to put
into context
oh it's just so nice it's I think in
Britain one of the things we do as well
is when we're trying to pull up these
histories we we have two versions which
is either you know we have the the
standout individuals like the
equiano's or we have people that we have
The Underdogs we just don't talk about
the enslaved the homogenous population
be enslaved but one of the things we're
raising quite a lot is the very ordinary
histories of the black people who lived
worked alongside in with communities
married the white population
um we've been here for so long and also
mixed race people have been here for so
long because of that but those histories
of these ordinary particularly Working
Class People just erased like um I was
talking to Lisa Williams of the
Edinburgh Caribbean Association one of
the episodes of the podcast I do and she
told this fascinating story about
Malvina Wells this stress woman who her
graves in Edinburgh I think is at St
John's Episcopal I'm not religious I'm
sorry if I butchered that churchyard um
and you can go and see and she died at
like the age of 82 she'd come over
attached initially to a rich wealthy
family there's but there's so many
records about her that we don't usually
have about working-class women at one
point she even managed to buy her own
house eventually she lost it but this
whole story about Marina Wells that
textured her ordinary life we don't get
that much we don't talk about that and
we separate these histories out into
okay someone somebody came over and they
got to rise to a very prominent position
as a black person and that's the only
person we're going to talk about and
everyone else was enslaved that's it
there's no middle ground and but those
middle stories those contextual stories
that's what makes up that full history
and that's what's fascinating another
person that was on the podcast who was
amazing as Annabelle Gilmore and she's
this PhD student at Birmingham and she's
um studying the black presence in
Warwickshire just and not even in terms
of who were the moves and shakers who
were the ordinary people in the
baptismal records but because because
this and this speaks also to this wider
sort of divide and conquer idea we
talked about in that white Working Class
People also really erased as well so you
just have baptismal records you just
have burial records you can you pull
their lives together those are the gaps
as well not just portrait shirts those
gaps they want to pull you into that
system of of recognition they want to
pour you into that system of basically
playing to the the the standards that
we've already set so that yeah so then
suddenly it's it's black people versus
working class white people yeah it's not
it's but if you're told well there's
only so much to go around
you're going to get that conflict and
people who are you know benefiting from
that they're happy to see it happen
um and this idea you know to just if you
have the exceptional individuals like
keep taking my mic goes off but if you
have exceptional individuals that
justifies Prince
that justifies the things that already
exist it justifies the systems that
exist and and things continue
all right I'm gonna bring you in it
because because there's been a lot of
nodding
um on this side of the so do you want to
respond to some of that yeah I mean I I
agree with the points they've been made
and I think
class is one of the big things that
we're talking about as well which which
very much encompasses race but also
transcends it and could potentially be a
point of being also an ally as well you
know and I think this point about
intersectionality is crucial because
obviously one of the defining
characteristics of this country is the
class system whereas sitting in the
middle of it now and that's one of the
things that we're very much you know
discussing and I completely agree that
you know for example with the Portugal
Gallery the recent historically that
people were on the walls is because they
were people of a certain class with
certain privileges and that meant they
were probably white then so it's like
you begin from that point and then you
kind of like reduce the pool and that's
what you end up with and so one of the
things that we want to do alongside you
know many things is to think about how
to show people of all backgrounds or
walks of life you know people whose
names we don't know because one of the
one of the sort of defining reasons for
acquiring someone is a known person with
a name who then accomplish things but
actually how could someone who doesn't
have a name speak to you about a certain
time so for example just to give you a
case in point uh David Bailey the
photographer you know Great British flag
Crystal with us for me some of his
greatest images are of people in the
East End of London you know not not his
photographs of celebrities or famous
people but these extraordinary images of
Eastern London we don't know the names
of these people but they tell you a lot
about British Society at that certain
point so we're kind of even thinking
through like structurally how do we how
do we think about you know our founding
principles and how do we test them and
see if they're still fit for purpose for
now and it goes back to those kind of
founding principles about
does the person have to be the names
known person because if it is if that is
the criteria then you've really narrowed
the pool if you're gonna there's a whole
bunch of people that just wouldn't you
can't
continue the very point you've made and
also like and you're also to that point
you're saying that everyone has to kind
of somehow uh subscribe or aspire to
Excellence and therefore achieving
something and you know being exceptional
and standing out but actually what's
interesting about Society is the
populace so that's something that we're
very much looking at and somebody would
have had to decide that that person's
name was important enough in the first
place to write down
right place what is exceptional yeah
yeah
um David I'm going to bring you in here
because one of the things I'm curious
about is you know we're having a
conversation about
really challenging a lot of you know the
maybe the founding principles of a place
like Harewood house and I'm curious for
you personally like how have you managed
to to get to this point like what what
made you okay with doing something that
I think a lot of people find super
comfortable even like they don't even
have to be Lords or Earls like just
regular you know people on the street
find it really difficult so I'm curious
how you've been able to get to here well
there wasn't any kind of uh
Road to Damascus moment you know the
light suddenly Sean we realized that
what we should be doing I mean partly
just it grew out of things that I was
interested in anyway that time wasn't
interested anyway artists that we were
interested anyway music that were
interested in anywhere I think for a lot
of people of my generation black music
Soul music reggae whatever it might have
been a big influence actually you know
the first time you came face to face
with black culture and it was a knockout
absolute knockout on the very memorable
yeah the Bob Marley concert so I'm lucky
enough to have been seen him live that's
fantastic so there was there's that sort
of background if you like and then
having the opportunity here having this
Resort if you like how do we talk about
this stuff here and that was a gradual
process of conversation between Diane
and me and people that we knew and how
how do we engage with that how do we
engage with that and I suppose the
conclusion we came to was that it
shouldn't be about us deciding what we
thought should happen there was actually
a question of working with artists
painters sculptures and Tom had an
exhibition here in 2015 about 15 yeah
um
and and working with them you know
talking what
how did they want to tackle that subject
how do they want to tackle that Legacy
and we've tried to do that and it's over
the whole range of of artists with um uh
painting sculptures musicians uh uh
theater makers uh wonderful and
Geraldine Connor who created this
fantastic theatrical production uh
Carnival Messiah which we performed in
2007 but even members of the cast here I
can see I've seen Loki in the back of
the audience actually so they could
those connections are still are still
still there so it was It was kind of It
kind of evolved rather than it being a
kind of yeah right this is it we know
what we want to do from now on there's
never been as clear as that one thing
that was clear was that something
that word evolved was crucial to it
wasn't a question of doing something a
big fashion showpiece on uh the day the
abolition of the slave trade was
announced and then that's it too you
think we've done that take that off for
this don't bother it anymore it has to
be something you go on and on and on
engaging with because it's a debate that
goes on and on and on it's way off being
a conclusion it's something that so many
people are terrified about just keep
talking about it and get more and more
people talking about it the only
negative really from from our point of
view has been that we're somehow now
seen as exemplars of all this and and
what's true of of Howard and how the
money was made here and how it was used
is not untypical that is institutions of
every sort education establishment Banks
the royal family the church
all of them were built all enhanced with
money from those places and they should
all be talking about it more honestly
I'm fed up with hearing myself saying
this thing
it's about audiences as well I mean and
I think what's extraordinary about what
you're doing but also entirely
appropriate and a no-brainer is the it's
the community leads you know it's the
community that's created the Leeds
Carnival like you need to you want to
and you need to bring your local closed
community here and to do that you've got
to have something to say to them and one
thing I will say is
um that you know this really isn't
binary it's Thomas's Point like you know
a lot of these cultures are very
manufactured very cynical because to go
back to the point about the research we
did you know it's it's actually our
repeat audience which tends to be uh
older middle class and white that
specifically wanted us to evolve the
collection and to make it more diverse
it's that audience that said we we love
the national Portugal we come all the
time we will always keep coming but we
wish that you were more diverse and more
in Britain that's a particular that's a
that's an audience that you might think
would say something different it
actually isn't so there's a fiction
about this being somehow antagonistic I
don't think it is and isn't that like
delightful in itself the the sort of
little tidbit around the assumptions we
make about what our audiences are
interested in and like what kind of
people are interested in what kind of
things okay so I'm just looking at my
clock we're about we're sort of in about
five minutes we're going to go to
questions so this is the time for you to
like get the little gray cells going
um the I guess I mean I have so many
other questions and it's been such a
generative conversation so far I suppose
maybe the the thing that I want to get
you all to respond to is you know coming
back to this idea of missing portraits
you know when we're having conversations
about some really mid like material
um
material gain people being materially
deprived you know all sorts of really
tough histories you know where is the
role of Art in this I mean maybe I'd
love to get um a response from all of
you but maybe David I'd start with you
is why do you think you know why why is
Art still important in these
conversations well culture we're talking
about I guess in a better word than art
I actually I hate the expression culture
wars but for me culture is about the
opposite of War because of our
identifying what is what is rich in this
place in this in this society and so on
and and exploring that and look looking
for points of uh contact rather than
points of conflict but an aside
um
I think that uh
all culture whether it's what is seen as
as high art oil paintings or watching
this popular art film all need to
they're about something whether that's
overt or or or or hidden or intrinsic
um so you you can't you can't get away
from it you know our all art forms are
dealing with the time that they're in
this house is full of uh it was
contemporary but it was when it was
commissioned Dan sometimes called it you
know the most uh uh the oldest
Contemporary Art Gallery in Yorkshire
because the paintings that were making
at the Reynolds portraits with the turn
of watercolors they were contemporary
artists at the time they were the hot
artists of that of that moment and
that's that's gone on and on and on the
Thomases of the 18th
Thomas maybe I'll turn to you
I mean I think there's this point about
context
it's incredibly important and I think
art can be a reflection of attitudes and
of
um culture so for me I guess why is Art
important in this regard it's because it
could be perhaps a rallying point it
could be a moment of interaction where
someone sees an idea expressed in a way
that they connect to which they can then
communicate to someone else they can
cause a knock-on effects to help change
people's attitudes along the way and
it's a subtle thing it's not like it has
to be a kapow moment but it could be
something which
um allows them to register or to gather
their thoughts in a way which can then
be
digested over time and delivered to
someone else and I think that's an
incredibly important thing because
really for me the important thing about
this is attitudes
it's not so much about the objects I
think portraits are fantastic but about
change of attitudes about a change of a
sense of responsibility what's the point
so if we can use these moments of
representation or in a different way to
help move attitudes forward and to kind
of rally people and that's that's
extremely useful but about it my worry
is that it becomes empty
what is the point Nick in in this time
of you know I mean I think it's such an
interesting time for Britain in terms of
renegotiating it's like you know I feel
like the UK is in this constant
renegotiation of its identity at the
moment I mean how how does the National
Portrait Gallery fit into that and the
role of art oh well I mean I think we
definitely have a role to play in a way
the more contested that is the more that
we have a role to play hopefully it also
kind of bringing people together and
realizing what actually unites us rather
than separates us
um I mean just you you ask the question
about you know what art or what or what
portraiture can do and I was thinking
about uh something that Thomas Carlisle
the 19th century historian who was
really one of the founding figures of
the national portugali said and he said
some very ugly things but he also said
some very beautiful things and one of
the really beautiful things he said
which kind of in a way inspired the
founding of the portugali was that a
portrait was a small lighted candle to
understand someone from the past it's
your point about light and dark and I
think you know the difference and he
compared it to reading books and he said
a portrait could be more revealing of
someone than it does in biographies and
I think that's the point that we can all
learn about the pastor of books which we
should do and and receive information
but I think what art can do is it can
help us hopefully heal and Achieve kind
of sub catharsis as well so thank you
well I guess David said I don't see art
as siled off I think that culture should
be taken as a smorgasborders everything
is putting together that book that
you're reading with the portrait of the
person that you're reading about
um and I think that are like there's
some culture is World opening that's why
it's important at a time when the
horizons might be seeming narrower
politically uh geographically in this
country than I think having access to
these different worlds these different
these portals into the past but also
into a contemporary space when you're
going to send that areas of the National
Portrait Gallery are going to like the
postal Museum these are really really
vital the thing is that we have such
restricted access now more and more and
these the spaces which are not seen as
talk about as highbrow or the spaces
don't have as much funding etc those are
being cut down even further so I don't
see it's just this one you know we
should just be preserving X Y and Z we
should be trying and fighting for every
single type of art form culture that we
can get because people need this diverse
range in order to build these worlds
that are fully technical rather than
just black and white
um and that that's how I feel about sort
of culture art situation but yeah in
short it's it's Horizon opening like my
richest experiences are going to you
know being taken to like stately homes
as a child but then also being taken to
Mad local art galleries where you had
local artists displaying these really
like off-the-works and this DIY stuff
the stuff that came from in you know the
early 20th century had sort of like the
Pitman painters and there's this artwork
that used to be fully from the ground up
this cultural tradition which we're
losing because of the lack of funding
because where everything else is being
squeezed so much so yeah culture's World
opening but unfortunately we need those
Horizons Origins even further I think
aren't as Horizon broadening can we give
our panel a round of applause thank you
[Applause]
I think that was fantastic
um and there was a lot there so can I
are there any brave souls that like to
ask some questions we also do have some
questions on the online chat
um and if you're watching online welcome
um and also please do put any questions
in the chat but does anyone want to to
ask a question from the room
yes down the back go ahead uh wait one
second actually there's a microphone
coming to you brilliant
hi um Tyrone Huggins I was just
wondering that the missing portraits the
idea that you have at the moment is not
to go back and try to add portraiture to
the past of the collection but to go
forward and to start to accumulate how
do you avoid
you know some of that issue of status
the status of the portraits and the
individuals you put into the portraits
that you're planning in the future and
then just another little bit adding on
to that
how do we get at the people in the
portraits from the past
great questions thank you complicated
question um well you can't I mean you
can't change the past can you it's not
we're not in which is not not Back to
the Future there's nothing however much
for me they want to there's nothing we
can do that's going to change our our
history so you start from that point
um I think in how you
um
I I think I I think that's important in
how you choose your subjects for the
portraits going forward I mean Arthur
isn't obvious one to stop somebody with
you well major figure in the in the
local community and so on I can now
actually announce for the first the
first time in public that our second
mission portrait is going to be the
actor David Harewood and the connections
there are kind of obvious
and again it's somebody we've put down
and I've got to know over the last
couple of years and he has delighted
agreed to be the second subject
um uh details to be to be uh to be
arranged during this year but we'll come
out at some point during this year so
we've tried to be careful about doing
that I'm not sure if that really
answered your question completely but
it's it's trying to find that kind of a
a real contemporary context talking
about what is happening today you can
talk about the past you can talk about
the history you can't you can't change
it you can't go back and insert things
in it to make more work what do you like
I I think that history can't be changed
but it can be illuminated to go back to
my point about polite and thought and I
think there what we talk about here
essentially being overlooked as in
people being overlooked so to go only
from forward would be to perhaps
continue that I think there's so many
individuals if we are going to celebrate
individuals who've existed and have
contributed to British society that
could be looked at in order to fill out
that history and that narrative so that
people can take pride in their history
and realize then just come from slaves
or you know and other people looking at
it Go and here's a valuable contribution
from people who I didn't expect I didn't
know but I hadn't heard about this
because there's so many points that in
my adult life in terms of history that
I've gone I did not know that person
existed and for me that would be truly
eliminated the places we've come to
doing this here is we're sort of
precursor if you like a missing portrait
series which we had an exhibition around
band called Bertie Robinson who's the
only recorded black servant whoever
worked here before he worked here from
around at the very end of the 19th
century through about two to about 1920
and that was sparked by finding a in a
in a draw in a Cupboard a box of letters
from his mother on what I know was
Vincent wasn't it was Vincent
to the ventilating Harvard to and fro
asking how's my son why isn't he writing
to be more he promised to send money
back he had an extraordinarily
contemporary Edge to it and it was a
whole very very detailed history of this
man and his family and their relations
uh uh and his descendants who still live
here got to know about this and came and
saw the show and it actually filled with
a lot of things about their own personal
family history so that's again
because you're already doing a lot I
just think it's something that could be
a national you know kind of seven yeah I
think this is the issue that at the
moment we're dependent on a top-down
remembrance so we're always going to be
dependent on sort of the individual or
the the institution
choosing the people or choosing a
project or having the will the cultural
will and the political will to do
something like pick someone from history
and illuminate them and obviously if we
had a much wider system of funding or
much wider access to the Arts than it
could be something where for example
there's this amazing project that
happened in Manchester which was called
Excavating the Reno which was
um it was run by local playwright called
Linda I can't remember her name's first
name is Linda and she basically there
was this club that all the young black
mixed with white children used to go to
as t as teenagers and it was this
amazing site like at one point I think
Muhammad Ali turned up and it was famous
and then it just got bulldozed
um and I think not I want to say 1976.
um and they lost the Reno and there
really been this huge standpoint this is
like this local histories I think of all
the time and she was like I want to
excavate the arena I want to dig up the
arena and I want to discover the
histories that have been left there in
the site that so many of us went to and
it could only be done with the backing
of the Whitworth Gallery So eventually
the Reno managed to take over a top
floor and I remember walking in I just
started crying immediately because like
I've seen suddenly this specific history
of like mixed race britons I hadn't seen
ever before
um but it could only have been done with
that institutional backing and they've
dug up all these amazing things like
lipsticks and cones and like cans of red
stripe and it was so evocative it was
exactly that Grassroots history
celebrating all new people there in a
wall of people who've been there many of
whom passed in these oral histories
there was all these different
installations but it was only because
the institution was involved that they
had the clout and the the
um funding to put that in a gallery
where people go and see it like it
probably could have been put in a local
Center would I've seen seen it there I
don't know if I would so it's again this
I think when we're talking about this
top-down Reliance at the moment it's
always going to be an unequal and we're
probably always going to subscribe to
this great person or who gets picked out
which individual rather than that more
DIY amazing history wide Arts funding is
is I think probably the solution so
Thomas I want to ask you a quick
question about because one of the one of
your commissions thank you Moya um and
also thank you to the questioner because
clearly you a few of you have like
touched and everyone's like I want to
say something
um which is fantastic thank you but so I
know that you had um the warm Shores
commission which was actually a piece of
public art and I'm curious about as
somebody who creates public art as well
like how does this kind of marry with
the conversation about you know dealing
with museums and Galleries and and how
do you negotiate that
I mean I I wanted to make a work which
the community were aware of they're
aware before it manifested before it was
plonked down you know I wanted something
that they could welcome and would look
forward to and I wanted them to be
involved in the process of creating it
um I also wanted to create a work which
talked about the windrust generation in
terms of the historical element and also
a potential future which acknowledged
the everyday nature which didn't make it
exotic
and which didn't make it another which
was like we are here we're taking space
we've been here for a long time
and and we'll continue to be here but in
a way that connected to anybody through
the humanity of these these figures
depicted and they're not particularly
individuals who
to part a lottery and now you get to be
famous it's nice again it's like trying
to incorporate elements of these people
even their stories or their actual
physical traits in a way which makes
people aware of our commonality
um and whether that's from whether
you're from Windrush generation whether
you're you know um you're descended from
the windows generation or whether you've
you've been in the UK you know five
different Avenues
um so it was a very
rewarding projects to do it's a
difficult one oh well I was just gonna
like did you did you need to find that
institutional backing did somebody come
to you like this question exactly
Council to their credit came to me and
and I I submitted my proposal and um I
was very happy when it was selected and
and they they stood by it and they they
supported it throughout the whole kind
of germination of it um
um
but it came from my practice I mean it I
said they're not on plimps you know I
don't want to dissect the whole practice
but they're standing on the ground that
you get to share with these characters
they're at nine foot tall so the scale's
different they're in bronze this
material of power that's been you know
with us for some thousands of years
which is used to represent the people of
worse well there is an absolute history
of lack of visibility
um particularly within um African
Caribbean communities we've got the
windrust scanner which is still ongoing
which has not been addressed properly
and so this was a moment of using
private funds to try and represent
um a a part a very important part of
British Society we've been I think
absolutely terribly treated you know
throughout history and more recently in
a way which wasn't othering and and
exotifying it was a way to say this is
that you're part of very fabric of this
this this country thank you and thank
you for you know sharing that with us
because I think it's also interesting to
think about or to learn about the
process that you went through and Nick
I'm going to bring you in here because
there's so much just if I just to go
back to the original question because
there's so much to say that's so
interesting and just your point I mean
I'm going to paraphrase but it was about
and it was really to David but it was
about you know are you looking back or
can you also sort of look forward and
I've kind of paraphrased your question
but I'm going to just take that as my
starting point and just to say you know
I mean certainly from our perspective
it's really incumbent upon us to do both
in that of course you know through what
we're acquiring now and commissioning
and we do commission which is unusual
and is a very particular thing of the
mpg we can certainly achieve a much more
inclusive and naturally representative
and diverse picture of Britain now but I
think it's also really important to look
back and to fill in the gaps where we
can and so for example
um I mean I've mentioned one or two
examples but I think I think one thing
to say is that this isn't just a kind of
like
exercise that you have to do that's
heavy is joyful it's creative like it
means we get to work with Incredible
artists so for example I shouldn't give
too much away but we've been able to
borrow things go on
um we've been able to like borrow works
of art biologists you know where we
don't have images but for example like
lebena hibbid's uh portrait of Tucson
you know uh who oversaw the Haitian
revolution or Elizabeth Payton's
portrait of Frederick Douglass from the
19th century and these incredible works
of Arts that you know because part of me
just wants to show extraordinary works
of art as well this is part of this like
in it this gives us the chance to
actually be much more creative about the
way we look back at the past and it's
joyful and expansive
go ahead go ahead
it pulls together what David has just
told us about a person on his
um in this house uh that he's just uh
told us a little bit about and is it
Jonathan's approach
that actually I would love to see
Thomas's version of that character as a
portrait
we've got commissions happening it's all
happening tonight it's all happening
tonight
um uh are there any other questions from
the room yes one over here just do you
want to wait for the microphone to come
to you so we can all hear you answer the
folks watching online can hear you as
well you know thank you very thank you
very much
um so
um really and and my enlightening um but
I do want to ask Thomas yeah that's the
right thing
yeah I'm researching you about culture
at the moment and I was wondering how
important do you think it is to look
back so this is a look back at original
Yoruba
culture our own
sculpture practice which is what I'm
doing my PhD in terms of partnership
accomplishment there portraits I can't
say the words today I'm scared
um because okay I'll be honest when I
when um the plinth got pulled down in
Bristol and there was a whole you know
January sculpture came on there and that
by Matt Queen
I think Matt have I got the names right
yeah somebody made a sculpture deadly a
surge of power and placed it on the
plinth there was a whole controversy
about how why how dare him and I I and I
think your your name came up that's how
I found out about you and I saw your
work and I was like yeah it's a more
school sculptures and well what I I
guess my question is how important is
yeah I think I remember thinking that
your work was quite abstract which was
great but then
um and I was I think I was kind of angry
that wait a minute the the black man's
making kind of the everyday woman with
the phone and then the wife let me be
honest I'm scared to say this out loud
because he's on camera as well so I hope
no one comes after me afterwards but um
you know there was outrage that why did
um my queen create this sculpture and
place it on the plane and I was I
actually thought wait a second how the
heck have they even made it so fast
what's the technology and that's kind of
what kind of how my practice changed and
I ended up making the Geraldine
sculpture but how important is it to
to actually have
you know resembling the people
portraiture
which in Yoruba is there's a word for
Aya Jara as opposed to just the abstract
and and both of them are actually
relevant so this is interesting in
Yoruba culture I've realized that both
sculptures work side by side but how
important is it because I know you you
were talking about all the other ways to
represent people and
people but how is important to actually
have resemblance portraiture
Thomas and Nick is you know how
important is it or how do you think
about perhaps portraiture of of people
who resemble individual people as well
as kind of more abstract yeah I mean
I've already said this thank you that
I've already said this evening that my
work is made and the knowledge that
that's going to happen anyway
so I'm not trying to replace that I'm
trying to add a bit of context and a
reference point for
a way to think about what people seem to
want in a way which dissects it a little
bit we might in a way that makes us ask
the question why
and and where's that come from
um so I think it is important to have
Works which represent people which are
literally of the people because we're
talking about memory and but I think
there's so many gaps so my point so why
whatever we can't keep going without the
gaps because then we're just celebrating
the same things
um so that's one thing but with in terms
of the
and if you want to get into the the
everyday woman element of it I mean I
was making that work years before so I
didn't respond to a situation I was
making a work about a person which
happened to coincide with an event that
happened
um and so that discussion developed
around around that work
and that's thing that's what we talk
about the culture war that gets
manufactured
so just your point about you know
portraiture and likeness and and what
does a good portrait look like and yeah
okay so on some level I'm just like an
art person and I just love working with
great artists and
I think one of the things we've been
trying to do is to really up the caliber
of that in the portugali to make sure
that because you know we've got
incredible things like from Holbein and
but to make sure that everything we're
programming and commissioning is just by
you know great artists however you
wanted to find that we can all have
debates about it but I think there's a
general kind of like understanding when
something is kind of great and it hits
you somewhere and one thing that I think
that does naturally is maybe expand the
fields of artists that you could work
with or who you would go to and I'll
just give you one example so when uh
eight years ago now is being interviewed
by the trustees for this job
they said to me if you could commission
a portrait of any sitter by any artist
what would it be and I said it would be
a portrait of Malala by sharing the
shafts because I was like this would be
the most incredible pairing of artists
and Seto but it would also expand in a
way some Horizons you know the fact that
Malala has chosen to come to the UK and
live soon as the youngest one of the
Nobel Prize would be depicted by this
extraordinary artist who isn't British
you know and it isn't just a British
figurative painter and I I don't know if
you saw but we actually made that happen
which was kind of amazing I was like
that exists yeah it's a thing it's a
thing and uh and you know there's a bit
of intuition too about when you when you
sort of pair an artist and Etc and it
will be chemistry but basically like all
all we do and it does encompass
diversity but it's also just about
artistic excellence and in a way the
more diverse you are the more you will
have access to Excellence that's the
point okay great we are almost a time
and we've and I've got some great
questions so hands up if there are any
other questions in the room okay no your
time
um David actually our next question is
to you as a volunteer here in the house
I'm often asked if there's a painted
portrait of the current Earl does he
plan him for himself to be represented
in the way his ancestors were
um yes there is a portrait
um made some years ago which actually
um again an exhibition around
portraiture of contemporary artist
called Jason Brooks who paints his very
large or then actually was painted in
very large very photorealist images of
not commissions but of people he he knew
so I'm really Keen as part of this
exhibition retrospective exhibition is
very important reporter of your of one
of the family members I we didn't go
home at all so on a very cold Sunday
morning we drove off to his uh studio in
the in the East End I assumed it was
going to be the portrait was going to be
of the hand I would I hadn't even
bothered to shave that morning
it was only when we were nearly there
but I was informed that it wasn't very
tall it was me so he sat we sat in this
freezing cold studio so cold that we had
to put cardboard on the floor to stop
your feet freezing to the concrete and
and Jason took half a dozen large format
photographs and painted from that this
huge portrait which is what six foot
high and 15 foot wide my my kids called
it big daddy
very very disrespectful
so actually it's of a of a sizer
Dimension it's very hard to find
anywhere in this house to put it up so
so I have a portal it's too big for
heroin house can I say it does exist but
it's it's downstairs it's a remarkable
portrait actually I think not you know
watching think of it because I was
actually very distant from it it wasn't
the classical thing again in the pasture
you sit in the artist studio and he'd
talk to you and he'd surround you with
the objects of your that you were most
associated with your books or your dogs
or whatever whatever it might be
um it wasn't like that at all nothing in
the portrait except that wow but blown
up huge gosh that's that's a real yeah
great
um a follow-up question and I also love
that it's a portrait that's too big for
this house like you know then then you
really know it's big
um the follow-up another slightly
different question but one also for you
David is
um how are the subjects chosen for the
missing portraits
um before
um
I mean finding people who who fit those
criteria they say if you have a genuine
contemporary connection with this place
which Arthur definitely does which David
definitely does and and the
um the future ones which we're thinking
I'll definitely do as well so we'll just
you know keep on it's not just of famous
black people it's actually people who
are have a genuine contemporary
collection with here all right Wicked
um we're almost at time so I have one
final question that I want all of you to
answer
um a very nice easy one
um which is at what point do we achieve
success in representation
[Laughter]
success and representation
yes perhaps perhaps that's too too broad
yes
when it stops being representation all
right it starts just being the norm okay
that's pretty good any any takers for
oh God yeah that's such a good question
I mean I well I I think to your point
definitely when there are obvious gaps
and and things that are excluded or not
addressed that's definitely something
that you can you can do better so
I agree I mean I kind of said before
um in the conversations that you know
when people just look at it as my wife
for example as a person or they're not
trying to they don't see this barrier in
front of them which is created by race
or or gender or something like that that
would be a moment but I think we're very
far away from that but yeah I think
when we don't feel the need for it when
we just haven't discussed with our
people that'd be an amazing place but
I'll probably be dead
might live forever David any last words
I don't think it's ever going to happen
really I think that's all there's always
going to be that uh that that desire to
see what people look like people both
because people will want to show
themselves because people will want to
show them and want to remember them so I
don't think it'll ever go away hopefully
it'll shift and change and become more
representative as the tools to represent
it with become more representative
become become more democratic if you
like and anybody can have a good
portrait taking of them child if they
know somebody who can point a camera in
the right direction and get the right
light you can have a nice portrait made
of it yeah and that wasn't the case 100
200 years ago there we go um
can we just give a huge round of
applause to our wonderful
[Applause]
from not being afraid of the dark
because we have lights you know to
talking about you know constant
Evolution and hopefully our work not
being seen in any particular way but
just about people and also being very
excited about the National Portrait
Gallery reopening in June I think we've
covered so much
um and for those who live nearby
um Dr Arthur France actually there's an
exhibition about the Leeds Carnival and
the and Dr Arthur France's life
um so you can come check that out I
think it's between Friday Saturday and
Sunday of your choosing
um and that's part and I think it's a
wonderful exhibition that I really
really encourage you to check out if
you're you know if you're online you
know come and come come to Hayward house
it'll be a good time
um but my thanks uh to Dr Nicholas
cullinan Thomas J Price Moya
thank you and David lasalles for a
fascinating conversation today and to
Harwood house an Intelligence Squared
for putting it all together the first
missing portraits exhibition after
France son of a small island will
continue until Sunday the 26th of
February so visit harewood.org to find
out more I've been near Smith Abdul
Majid I hope you've enjoyed our
conversation today and thank you so much
for joining us
thank you